Another important technique in
fine tuning the experience for
assistive technology users
involves ensuring that
only the relevant parts of the page
are exposed to assistive technology.
There are several ways to ensure that a
section of the dom does not get exposed
to accessibility APIs or
is exposed only to accessibility APIs.
Firstly, anything which is explicitly
hidden will also not be included
in the accessibility tree.
So anything which has a visibility
hidden, or display none CSS style.
Or uses the HTML5 hidden attribute,
will also be hidden from
assistive technology users.
However an element which is
not visually rendered, but
not explicitly hidden, is still
included in the accessibility tree.
One common technique is to include
screen reader only text in an element
which absolutely
positioned far off screen.
Of those we have seen,
it's also possible to provide
screen reader only text via
an aria label attribute.
Or an aria labeled by or
aria describedby attribute referencing
element which is otherwise hidden.
The instructor notes have a link to some
more information on providing screen
reader only text.
Finally, aria provides a mechanism for
excluding content from assistive
technology which is not visually hidden
in the form of an aria-hidden attribute.
Applying this attribute to an element
effectively removes it and
all of its descendants from
the accessibility tree.
With the exception of any element which
is referred to via an aria labeledby or
aria describedby attribute.
For example, in an online slide deck
you might need to have next and
previous slides pre rendered and
ready to slide in.
But not make them visible to users
who are viewing the deck via
assistive technology,
until they're all the way on the screen.
[BLANK_AUDIO]